[Music]
there's nick bosa standing around at the
ohio state university pro day workout he
decided not to work out a business
decision that more top talent need to be
making because the last thing you need
to do when the hay is in the barn and
the draft is a month away you get
yourself injured and you are costing
yourself money sydney jones remember
that name two years ago at the
washington pro day workout popped his
achilles tendon ended up being a second
round pick instead of a first rounder
that is what these guys are trying to
avoid what is the gain
what is the risk and for nick bosa there
isn't much if any gain there's plenty of
risk no yeah there is no gain i mean i
think between what he did at the combine
which was extremely impressive and then
what he's done on film and i know he
didn't play much football this year
because he heard his groin and he made a
business decision during the season too
to go you know what i'm not going to
rush back and you know tear my groin
again or get re-hurt somewhere else to
where i fall out of the top five or top
ten because i tried to rush back for
week six a big ten football play and
therefore i ruined the rest of my career
and chance to make money he made a smart
decision i like it and he is another guy
you talk about we just talked about
quinn williams on a tv segment where
it's just
like it's guaranteed anybody to talk to
it's he's top three pick top four
there's no way he's getting out of that
that's how impressive he is when you
break down the film so that inspired
today's pft live draft the most
memorable nfl business decisions and
this is broad this can be anything you
want it to be unlimited i know that's
why i don't like this because you're
going to get pulled stuff that i never
thought well but here's the thing
it was about 45 minutes ago you said
during a break so what's the draft today
yeah anytime that happens it's like i
got this one he hasn't even thought
about it yet and this one is not an i
got some good ones though i do all right
do we do the i guess we gotta do that
we're doing rocks paper scissors with
this idiot right there all right we're
ready you got this down rock paper
scissors shoot you always say rocks yes
rock okay right way you didn't even know
what the second word is i got the first
pick go ahead go ahead have fun you
[Laughter]
no uh okay um i think the the first one
i am going to go with is i'm going to
pick
john elway okay john elway here we go
great business
you like that one yes i mean you talk
about a business
decision oh yeah the indianapolis colts
might draft me at number one i don't
want to play in indianapolis i want to
play on the west coast somewhere like
that oh okay yeah you're going to draft
me fine see you later i'm going to go
play baseball for the yankees and i'm
going to do that and until i get what i
want and john elway made a business
decision a lot like an eli manning where
he drew a line in the santa against a
team that was going to draft him and
said no i don't envision my career
playing there i don't like the uh the
way that organization's going and
because of that he forced his way to the
denver broncos to become the starting
quarterback went to five super bowls won
two of them storied career one of the
greatest quarterbacks of all time that
was a big time just business decision
well look i'll see your john elway and
i'll raise you and eli manning because
eli manning was able to avoid the team
he didn't want to play for without
having baseball as an option elway at
least had some other professional sport
he could have gone and played all eli
manning did with the assistance of his
father archie was to say
i don't want to play for the chargers
hey chargers you got the first overall
pick in the draft i don't want to play
for you and
in a league where there's this obsession
with oh you get drafted that's where you
go you don't have any control over this
process he got his dad involved and this
was all eli but getting dad involved
took the focus and the flack off of eli
so archie was the bad guy eli is just
the kid that's doing whatever dad tells
him to do eli wanted nothing to do with
the charges he regarded the organization
as dysfunctional he wanted to play for
another team he wanted to play for the
giants and it worked out just perfectly
15 years ago next month when eli manning
ended up making the ultimate power play
with no
leverage that's what's amazing didn't
want it right no i j i don't want it
right and it worked yeah it did it
worked you know and again i mean it's
hard for a team in that instance to go
wait all right so we're going to draft
you we want you to be the face of the
franchise and the quarterback and this
guy doesn't want to be here yeah they
were stuck in a tough spot the san diego
chargers at the time but think about
this yeah we're talking about how
antonio brown's power play has created
this new frontier for for play yeah eli
manning did it 15 years ago and no one's
done it since yeah you're right you're
right it was a very rare thing and hey
the mannings are they're extremely
intelligent people and smart and
understand the business and and the
angles to play let alone being
phenomenal at football as well i know
i've been on eli a little bit about his
play as of late but still
has been awesome he was awesome in
college and that was a big time move i'm
never going to hate on a guy for making
a business decision i'm going to go down
like a similar road here with a similar
type of thing bo jackson okay bo jackson
made a big time business decision got
drafted by the tampa bay buccaneers
right 1986 also found out that the
buccaneers were one of the the owner was
one of the reasons that
bo jackson wasn't able to play baseball
his last year at auburn because you know
apparently the the owner said something
that was against nca rules or admitted
that he had gone out to dinner i can't
remember the exact story that he had
gone out to dinner with bo jackson and
that caused him his eligibility to be
done and he couldn't play baseball so he
said you know what i don't like you the
hell would you tampa bay buccaneers i'm
gonna go play baseball and that's what
he did he went and played for the kansas
city royals i mean bo jackson arguably
you know he's in the pantheon of gods
for the greatest pure specimens we've
ever seen right i mean when you really
talk about it him dion sanders lebron
james i mean these are michael jordan
freaks of freaks as far as athletes are
concerned but he goes and plays baseball
and a team reaches out to his agent goes
what do you think would bo be interested
in coming back uh oh who what team is it
the oak the the los angeles raiders oh
i'll be interested in that the raiders
draft him the next year in the draft
because the bucks lost the the uh
ability to retain him and he goes on and
and plays for the raiders but here's the
thing what let's look at this [ __ ]
you're looking up stuff right now how
big how good of a business decision is
it when football ended up destroying his
baseball career okay you could argue
this guy would have been a hall of fame
talent he would have been generational
he was one of the best baseball players
ever but because he made the business
decision to play football he ended up
destroying a potential hall of fame
baseball career so this would be one of
the worst business decisions ever well
he i don't know i
disagree first of all hey he could have
been a hall of fame running back too i
mean there's never been and he suffered
the injury playing football okay but he
might have suffered the injury jumping
up a wall to catch a fly ball the next
year of baseball we don't know what
would have happened so how many how many
guys need hip replacements from catching
fly balls
in baseball no not many you're right but
there's been a lot that have had hip
surgery alex rodriguez did because
you're twisting on your hip either way i
don't care you're trying to be a jerk
and lawyer me out of this by changing
the subject at the time that was a big
time business decision and man look at
these highlights of bo and you want to
talk about legs and butt holy legs and
butt no wonder he could run by everybody
i'm going to give you a different kind
of business decision and i am going to
stay within the manning family and the
general business decision was peyton
manning's willingness to take a dive
whenever he needed to take a dive in
order to live another day and it used to
be a bad thing right that was why jim
everett pushed the table over on jim
rome because everett used to take a dive
to avoid getting hit right peyton
manning made it fashionable and the
ultimate act in the final season of
peyton manning's career the divisional
playoffs against the pittsburgh steelers
not only did he take a dive he got up
and kept going and threw a pass while
the broncos were losing in the fourth
quarter that should not have been
allowed this is the i don't think it is
anymore no i mean i'm no one touched me
my guy's open first down off goes the
drive that was unbelievable i mean that
really was you know i forgot about that
play that was a you're right pittsburgh
was kind of in troll in control of the
game right there and it kind of swung
the pendulum uh in their direction
totally i didn't really know we've been
down this road before screw that word
tune into chris sims unbutton today if
you enjoyed pendulum we'll have plenty
more well longer
english words um okay so that's not a
bad one i don't know if that's that
great of a business decision i mean and
you went with the same family twice
don't even try sometimes you didn't even
the guy really didn't make a business
decision there listen he did not make a
business it's very difficult for you to
try to trash it after you spent 45
seconds man that's great i'd forgotten
about that oh that's really something oh
that's not a very good one it was a
great play it has nothing to do with
business that's where i'm going with
that okay all right now let's go back to
business here and let me win this draft
because i've been dominating you in
these drafts lately listen the big cat
approach is not going to work so it
works for him it's not working no i mean
yesterday's college draft was domination
okay emmett smith 1993. that was one of
the best business decisions i can ever
remember
as a young man or growing up and just
going whoa you know arguably well he's
definitely one of the two best running
backs in football it was emmitt smith
and barry sanders at the time the dallas
cowboys had just won the super bowl in
1992. we know the run game and that big
offensive line were so important to what
they do and he said you know i'm not
coming back i sat he sat at all a
training camp and dallas called his
bluff and oh we're talented enough it
doesn't matter we'll get away with it oh
well the big bad cowboys started out
owen two and owen two meant cha-ching
for emma smith where jerry jones gave
him the money he wanted and of course
emmitt smith the cowboys went on to be
the number one seed in the nfc and win
the mvp in the super bowl in the georgia
dome in that super bowl against the
buffalo bills in the rematch yeah and
the only reason you even thought of that
is we talked about it earlier this week
because we've been advocating that
ezekiel elliott should do now what
emmitt smith did in 1993 yeah otherwise
you wouldn't even thought oh well so so
you're going to give me credit for
thinking of something but yet like just
like make me seem like an idiot because
i wouldn't have thought about it you
never would have thought
that was one of the most the biggest
holdouts of of my lifetime as far as nfl
is concerned all right this one is
before your lifetime and actually it's
so old it's before mine and what we've
been
critical of the new york giants this
week for the way to handle the odell
beckham jr situation the way dave
gettleman handled his press conference
the i don't have to tell you anything
attitude not gonna go like the giant
sneaker game no i'm going with the
decision
by the national football league and its
teams once they realized the money that
could be earned from televising their
games the new york giants could have
said
hey
we want to go do our own tv deal we want
to keep all the money we're the big
market team nobody cares about cleveland
or baltimore or this they care about new
york right so we keep our ticket
receipts we're keeping our tv money but
when the nfl decided in the 60s to share
revenue that is the thing that unlocked
what we have now because the league was
never dominated by one or two rich teams
they made sure that everybody had money
they made sure everybody had revenue and
then that would later become salary cap
and free agency and even though the
patriots have cracked the code and have
destroyed any semblance of parity the
system that's in place where every
franchise is profitable and every
franchise has billions even if no one
shows up for their games because of the
revenue sharing that happens at the
tv level and the giants were the ones
who were giving up the most when this
all happened right a selfless act by the
new york giants that was the best
business decision the nfl has ever made
that's the best business decision that's
ever been made in connection with
football because it's contributed to
what we've had for really 50 years where
the idea is anybody in theory can win
because the money is being divided
relatively equally by the team okay i
mean you're going to the stretch here
you're giving them credit for the salary
capital free agency it's 30 years what
happened but that was the one business
decision that went to the way the nfl is
constructed that made it easier for
these other teams to to be relevant it
has been like baseball jim carrey i've
had better okay i've got better all
right i've seen better picks by you no
you're just that's just sad yeah stop
saying that you're boring no he's not
stats isn't saying anything he said
boring about your picks that's tell them
i won the draft stats didn't win
anything yeah you didn't win dominating
all right um some other ones that i
considered but didn't make it the kirk
cousins business of course paving the
way for franchise tag
out of town
well but that was a business decision
that he that his last it was his going
out of business decision it was his last
nfl play when he got out of derrick
henry's way to preserve himself for the
next year and he ended up retiring i
almost thought about going deion sanders
running the 40 like showing up in his
his fur coat and just running the 40 and
saying that's it that's all i got for
you and leaving because that was a
pretty cool business decision too i
almost threw that out there
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports